well it was supposed to be the dawn of a
new era in politics but instead to
change UK is struggling to break through
the party's brexit spokesperson is Anna
Sabri she joins us now thank you for
being here with us in the studio this
morning change UK polling around three
percent you lead candidate in Scotland's
defected to the Lib Dems what what's
going wrong
well look we were form five weeks ago if
that actually I think I actually think
we do remarkably well where we are up
against these big goliaths and I think
my big takeaway from usual is when I go
to the rallies and actually just out and
about I genuinely believe there is a
real thirst in our country millions of
people believe nobody represents them
they want that sensible centrist
moderate but progressive politics
accepting that all the political parties
are responsible for the breaking of
politics and and I believe genuinely
belief we offer the change the people of
this country are desperate to achieve so
why isn't it cutting through I mean you
say I know you suppose him and you say
that you only set up a few weeks but I
mean look at the brexit party well 34
percent they're a new party as well well
know that sorry I'm so sorry at the
brexit party is just another extension
of the nigel Farraj ego party that's
been in one way or the other one guys
are another for the last 20 odd years I
was told in 2015 just before five days
before the general election I was going
to lose my seat my majority went up from
400 to 4200 I was told in 2017 five days
before the general election I was going
to double my majority it went all the
way down to 900 so I mean we're polling
the biggest the most important poll of
course is what happens on Thursday and
there is all too playful I really do
believe that if you don't do as well as
you hope in the European elections and
dude if you don't win any seats is that
it for changing absolutely not as far as
I'm concerned as I say I believe there
is this real thirst out in the country
to get back to that centrist moderate
progressive form of politics accepting
that British politics is broken that the
majority of those political parties said
all of them are part of that breaking
and that none of them are actually
offering up the solutions that we need
to men
and the divisions in our country to sort
out brexit and tackle all the big
burning issues that are out there and
one person who perhaps doesn't quite
share your optimism is one of your
candidates rachel johnson have a little
look at what rachel johnson said she's
your top camp candidate in the southwest
and she said train GK is a terrible name
I'm jumping on another sinking ship with
change UK we hope it's not sinking but
it's not riding the ocean waves I think
it will be a slow build a reverse
macaron well look I can't speak for
Rachel I mean she is a Johnson they have
a bit of a history of state same stuff I
tell you what though I'd rather have her
than Boris it's very helpful though
thank you
look everybody's entitled to their own
opinion I mean the most important thing
is our strong message and that is what
voters absolutely know and understand we
believe in a people's vote we believe in
remaining in the European Union we
believe the best feel is the current
deal that we have with the European
Union and on that she and I and in fact
everybody else unlike any other party
are absolutely agreed and she also said
that it was a mistake not to ally more
closely with some of the other remain
parties but we work with all these
parties we have been doing that through
the people's vote campaign that's why I
the beginning vindicate didn't do it no
look back at some of the things that for
example Chris Lesley it was pretty
dismissive no I think we really have to
be very honest about this Sophie I mean
I took the view that my party the
Conservative Party had left me I leave
then my values my principles were
exactly the same I'd worked with people
like Chris and chucker of course in the
people's vote campaign which was always
cross party a great way to work and
we've done that extremely successfully
and when I was looking at what to do
next I looked at obviously Lib Dems I
looked at just sitting as an independent
but I knew I had in depth and you did
consider joining the Lib but the first
political party ever join was the
Liberals and of course I worked with the
Lib Dems in government to the point
where people like Jess Winston I
consider a friend I looked at all of
that but I took a very firm view one the
British politics is broken and that
includes all the parties and secondly
the people I actually have more in
common with our people like chucker
and Chris and Gavin and and Luciana Mike
gates
those are the people in joan line those
are the people i just have more in
common with and we want to create
something new we want to deliver the
change that as I say I believe millions
of people in our country are crying out
for I mean there's been really this
doesn't know that Heidi Allen is
actually considering a flirtation with
academic I'd that quite remarkable in a
segment and I think the most important
thing is let's talk about these
elections on Thursday let's talk about
the great issues that are out there
let's talk about brexit let's talk about
what we're going to do is we face what I
believe will be a national crisis
amounting to an emergency as we go
towards the end of October with that
cliff edge there and we heard it in
Steve Barclays interview that he did
with you where he and other government
ministers contenders for this leadership
in the Conservative Party are making it
very clear it will be no deal and in the
event of no deal I'm going to put my
country first and I won't hesitate to
say in the event of no deal we have got
to revoke we have got to stop this thing
that is destroying British business that
is blighting our politics and is
desperately affecting the credibility of
this country abroad I mean No Deal if
you believe and some of the
Conservatives could happen sooner than
we think
absolutely we're saying that there was
going to be a decision between revoke or
no deal exact that deal doesn't go
through so if their withdrawal agreement
fails to pass again in June will change
UK their MAC revoke oh if it's a
question between No Deal or a vote
absolutely no deal would be catastrophic
for this country who says that this
government its own impact assessments
have shown that it would be a
catastrophe it would be profoundly bad
for our country and you've got to put
the country's interests first and in
that instance I'm actually we have
talked about this before because we had
a variety of debates as you know we've
had legislation and I put forward an
amendment that said that in the event of
these things revoke has got to be a
realistic option and I would vote to
revoke rather for that country to leave
without a deal which would be a disgrace
because it would not be in anybody's
interest in this country and also I
really do believe the majority of
British people did not vote for us to
leave without a deal in fact they were
promised we would have a deal before we
left
you know Theresa hasn't got a deal she's
got this withdrawal agreement it is not
the deal we were promised but the idea
that we leave without any deal and the
threat to peace in Northern Ireland the
damage to jobs to our economy is so
great when a union with voc and stop
this whole madness but that would be the
stuff of economic madness okay clearly
not everyone agrees with that assessment
but Anna Seabury thank you very much for
coming on the program this morning